pagan magic a berserker by birthright
and jumping through time viking's
valhalla has as much depth and drama as
its predecessor but where does it go
from here the season is over and we've
got questions
there is no going back from here only
forward
the first season finale the end of the
beginning centers around the battle for
karaget the capital of viking norway in
keeping with the series dedication to
portraying real world complexities and
morality and politics the battle is
anything but simply good versus evil
sure fans were unlikely to root for the
conniving yarl olaf or the borderline
extremist yarokura but the issue was
muddied by human sacrifice brutal civil
war and a flurry of double and triple
crosses on both sides just who played
who in what order and why all have major
ramifications for the surviving
characters put simply harold betrayed
katagat then portrayed olaf and kora for
katagat but korra had already betrayed
harold and fed him false information
olof portrayed them both knowing that
harold would betray him and he used that
betrayal to weaken both karaget and
koro's army thereby leaving him the
strongest power when the dust settled by
the time my army arrives i would be the
strongest dial left in norway
maybe the only one or so he thought even
when that bulk nut is unraveled many
questions remain
why did olaf let harold live after his
double cross is olaf truly the christian
fundamentalist he claims to be is harold
the christian he claims to be both
betrayed fellow christians for pagans or
pagan sympathizers was korra truly
blessed with second sights implying the
pagan seer was still alive perhaps most
importantly of all was olaf a master
manipulator or just lucky
meanwhile on the other side of the north
sea the end of the beginning follows
another power struggle the battle for
the throne of england though compared to
catagout this battle was fought more
with machinations and masses of troops
the fight was no less treacherous and no
less significant the principal players
were the interim viking king forkbeard
the viking queen alphaview the norman
queen emma and the royal advisor godwin
if the herald slash olaf slash korra
knot was convoluted then the competition
in london was the world's biggest ball
of twine just as in catagout the exact
level of each player's duplicity will
presumably have a major bearing on the
series future
you
you were part of this
indeed i was it's clear that forkbeard
emma and godwin all conspired to remove
the troublesome alpha view from the
pitcher but just how far they were in
league with each other matters one of
the key moments that began the
conspiracy was godwin's killing of
edmund emma's stepson and heir to the
english throne as emma seemed to care
for edmund it's difficult to imagine she
was in on that particular part of the
plot the scheme also took fork beard
away from the throne and back to norway
conveniently leaving only emma in
england and with a claim to the throne
could it be that emma and godwin
conspired behind forkbeard's back it
will be up to us to make this work
us and for godwin the newly appointed
earl of wessex could he be setting his
sights on an even higher position
historically the biggest viking
settlements outside of their native
norway sweden and denmark were in
iceland greenland the british isles and
normandy france at the end of the first
season of vikings valhalla essentially
every one of those territories is in a
state of political flux and faces a
number of questions about its future
aside from iceland which seems to be
doing just fine
england is left in emma's hands though
she is married by a christianity to the
newly crowned king knut he is also
married by a pagan tradition to danish
queen alphaview emma being norman is
neither true viking nor true saxon and
so her hold on england is tenuous knut
is away in his native denmark to repel a
ruse invasion from the east meaning
denmark is likely in the hands of a
temporary ruler probably a yarl norway
was just ravaged by civil war much of
its population lost catagets has fallen
and now forkbeard has sailed into the
city to take it meaning norway will
likely have three different kings in the
span of a day greenland 2 faces an
uncertain future though it's only
mentioned in the series it's clear that
greenland's leadership has always been
questionable especially now that lake
eriksen is left
though emma's claim to the english
throne is both tenuous and challenged at
the end of season 1 she nonetheless has
the highest combined score when it comes
to both rightful claim and actually
being in england for the moment she has
an unparalleled amount of authority to
enact her will depending on her level of
involvement in edmond's death the first
item on her docket will most likely be
avenging her beloved stepson the clever
and ever perceptive emma noticed the
small stab wound on edmonds body and
immediately accused godwin of her
stepson's murder strange things happen
in these types of accidents your
highness strange
i would call it miraculous assuming she
was not involved in this plot she
clearly has her primary suspect will
emma have godwin killed his revenge and
as is always the issue in this tale of
honor responsibility and competing
allegiances can she kill him godwin is
after all the new earl of wessex and a
trusted advisor to forkbeard would
forkbeard kill emma in retribution and
might emma's practicality convince her
to keep the clever littlefinger s godwin
alive in her own employee
godwin isn't the only conspirator who
may soon find themselves on emma's
chopping block the same is true for
alphaview but despite emma's momentarily
having the upper hand over alphaview
both women are in equally precarious
positions while king khannout is away in
denmark emma can never be sure where his
love truly lies further she can't forget
that her marriage was a rushed one and
one performed for political gain
alphaview has two sons and both are with
knute help of you may be in jeopardy but
so is emma killing the mother of knut's
sons and forkbeard's grandsons might
just invite even worse than a guild of
thieves into her home
olaf managed to persist throughout the
entire season through some mixture of
wiles and luck in the final moments of
the season finale however olaf is
finally left in a position that
threatens to use up all of his remaining
luck and his wiles alone may not be
enough to save him about a minute after
taking katagat and proclaiming himself
the new king of norway olaf receives the
news that fort beard's fleet has sailed
into the harbor
for olaf the oral who betrayed
forkbeard's son king knuth the fleet
likely means death in his last moments
on screen olaf throws off his regal
cloak and runs off into karagat is he
about to die a warrior's death in combat
or will he be able to flee to safety is
there any such place in a country full
of his enemies
during the sacking of category freitas
and harold escaped the city on horseback
riding into the mountains of untamed
norway like olaf they face the question
of where to go for olaf the issue is the
infamy gained during his and koro's
conquest of norway and the extermination
of its pagan populace for freitas and
harold the issue is the opposite most of
their allied cities and settlements have
been conquered while harold is a
christian he has made it clear that
freitas is more important to him than
his faith and so even if he could find
sanctuary in christian norway he
wouldn't without his beloved on top of
that freitas is more pagan than ever
having embraced her prophesized role as
the last daughter of uppsala
oh yes
the last
with none of her fellow greenlanders
left alive save for a bloody berserk
glaive and with norway heavily
christianized freitas will have a hard
time finding safety anywhere close to
catagout creator jeb stewart did tease
at herald and whoever will still follow
him have a long journey in store telling
looper we're going to take them out of
scandinavia where they might end up is
anyone's guess
as the sword is carried by the cross
much blood
pouring
like fountains throughout its first
season vikings valhalla was deliberately
vague in its portrayal of supernatural
phenomena at times the visions seen by
people like freitas and korra seem
almost factual while at other times it
seems obvious that any perceived
otherworldliness was simply the product
of zealousness and hallucinogens a
well-documented historical tradition but
as as the story progresses it may become
harder to remain ambiguous one of the
most momentous occurrences in freitas's
life is her vision of the seer the
prophet who played a major role almost
200 years earlier for her to have seen
the seer as he actually appeared in
vikings would either take an astounding
coincidence or the legitimate existence
of magic even during the events of
vikings the seer was allegedly centuries
old and his appearance though possibly
explainable by natural causes appear
truly inhuman ephratus is indeed the
last sacred pagan champion in an
increasingly christian northern europe
where will vikings valhalla decide to
land on its own issue of magic realism
whether or not the crew behind viking's
valhalla ever takes a stand on the
reality of magic in their world the
battle between competing religions is
very real and a large part of the show's
setting the tension between christian
vikings and pagan vikings is felt in
every episode few of the show's
characters are able to avoid choosing a
side in the conflict though siri's
protagonist late is seemingly able to do
so for almost the entirety of eight
episodes late performs his stone-faced
outsider act for anyone who broaches the
subject of the gods and only drops the
charade in the last moments of the
season finale as his lover liv dies in
his arms she asks late if he believes in
the old gods as she does though he
hesitates he eventually caves and
reassures her just moments too late that
yes he follows traditional norse
paganism
i'll join you
join you i promise i promise thanks to a
number of clues throughout the series
however it's possible that lathe may
actually be embracing christianity
leif's infamous father eric the red
became a legend throughout the entire
viking world due to his berserker nature
he was a killer through and through
whether in wartime or peace and his
unhinged bloody melees are what earned
him the name the red leaf an apple from
that red tree is always forced to wonder
how far from it he fell or how close he
remains lave spends the majority of the
season maintaining his cool killing
minimally and keeping his temper in
check it's not until liv's death that
the berserker inside him is truly
unleashed his whirlwind of axes
certainly harkens back to tales of eric
the red but the truth may be more
complex while the savage fury in which
leif ends the season may simply be a
relatively justified reaction to the
death of his partner it remains to be
seen how red late really is
it is likely that season 2 of viking's
valhalla will take place either directly
after or soon after the end of the first
season but it is far from a given
showrunners jumped almost 200 years
between the end of vikings and the start
of vikings valhalla showing their
willingness to skip through history to
get to its media's parts on top of that
the latter half of the season introduced
the children and grandchildren of some
of the show's main characters well
season two of vikings valhalla shift
like the start of season one from our
main characters to their children given
the amounts of story left to be told for
lay freitas and harold it's unlikely but
a future season could certainly
chronicle the children's crusade perhaps
somewhat literally given the increasing
percentage of vikings who believe in
christ ultimately the win where who and
how of future vikings valhalla seasons
are all up in the air though the air is
sure to be thick with smoke and the
screams of viking raiders
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one